it's time to declare the question and
answer period in your household over
p-switch got one more day of queuing
that's right in your household lads here
for what's a lot I'm not gonna waste my
shot Tony
good to see you all here are a few
stories we think you will be talking
about today
there are disturbing new accusations
this morning against our Kelly from his
ex-girlfriend
Ezreal Clary last March Clary and
another of Kelly's girlfriends Joycelyn
savage defended the singer and a CBS
this morning interview with Gail now in
an exclusive interview with the Sun
Larry says she quote lied on Gail during
that interview she says she was
brainwashed by Kelly
she also says Kelly has hundreds of
victims across the u.s. who will not
come forward Larry says it's blackmail
some of them into silence by reporting
them in degrading sex acts including
abusing children I know a lot of women
out there are embarrassed and are
accumulated in are ashamed to come out
you have to ask him if you could go to
the restroom you would have to knock any
time you entered it or left a room
you're gonna make calls without him
knowing Larry also says Kelly beat her
and forced her to have group sex with
other men and women up to five times a
day Kelly is in jail awaiting trial on
sex crime charges a lawyer for our Kelly
tells CBS News that Clarys allegations
are not true I'm not surprised that she
has changed her story at the time she
was 21 I think now she was 22 because we
asked her all those things which she
denied and said it wasn't happened she
hadn't been brainwashed she wasn't
forced to do anything but I still keep
thinking she's a young woman I don't
think she fully grasped how damaging
this whole situation is so we will see I
think there's more to come from her the
question will be of course if other
women come forward zactly that she
alleges this has happened every time
somebody says something other women do
come forward so we will see but my heart
goes out there because I do think that
she needs need some help
you